one of our favorites here on the Rich
Eisen show is kind enough to join us
fresh off of the big week to win in the
Coliseum against the New Orleans Saints
Los Angeles Rams safety Eric Weddle how
are you Eric rich my man
how are you brother bro doing great how
has it been to be back here in Southern
California after your Baltimore jaunt
that you had it like for you brother
it's been it's been great it's uh
there's nothing like California when
you're born and raised in California you
can't take California out of you're out
of you when you when you've been here
your whole life
and I love my Stan Baltimore I still
miss everyone there and miss my model
teammates but I'm a part of a great
organization a great team culturally and
shoot man we just off a big win and now
we're on to the next one what's it like
when you hear on the sidelines that
breezes hurt and maybe he's not coming
back what does it happen for you Eric
how's that spread yesterday well we yeah
we uh we didn't have any idea until we
saw Bridgewater come out I believe the
third or fourth series whenever we never
breeze one out and it's kind of a shock
you don't as a player you don't really
know what is going on with Drew you're
hoping he's okay you know you don't you
don't wish any ill will on anyone that
that you're playing against you always
want to be out there with the best and
competing and and so forth and you see
Teddy out there and and honestly you
kind of have to rule your self back in
and you know you just bring the guys
together and let them know like look no
matter if Drew's in there Teddy or
anyone else we got to go out there and
focus concentrate on every play and play
our style again because you can easily
get wrapped up in the whole backups in
there you can kind of be at ease or
you're not as focused and then gosh the
backup goes in there and torches your
defense and now you're in the now you're
in a game that you should have been
playing well and you're in a tight game
late in the fourth quarter so I'm glad
that and pretty proud of how we
responded in those circumstances and
came away and played well throughout
okay so is it again I know you're new to
the team but this is your 13th rodeo in
the NFL here 13th season so you
obviously have the resume is it your job
on this team to be the one that pulls
everyone together Eric no I mean I don't
look at it is my job it could be anyone
we're very it's a very unique group like
we all we all have personalities we all
work extremely hard we all have each
other's backs oh and no one's above the
defense no one's above getting coached
no one's above getting if I if I need to
get tailed you know hey you better step
it up or you need to make this play like
it's it's a it's a very genuine real
group so I just think in that moment I
just wanted to reiterate to the guys
like look man we got to play even more
at another level now that Bridgewater is
in to get this thing rolling in art
direction so we don't have a step back
and the way the flow of the game was it
was in balance for much of the game
until late in the third quarter so we
just had to keep the pedal down and keep
the focus and that's what we did Eric
Weddle Ram safety here on the Rich Eisen
show and I don't know if it was
obviously maybe them having a little bit
of an issue with their starter being out
or not but it was just a 60 yard from
scrimmage day for camara I'm wondering
what you guys did to bottle him up Eric
I thought our run defense from from the
onset was paramount it's been a point of
emphasis from last season you know first
half of the season last year we weren't
very good we shorted up the second half
of the season but it's been it's been a
key emphasis to be good on first and
second down and way if we get to third
and Long's man let our let our guys work
let our backend work and when you got
the best player in the world on defense
and you got edge rushes with clay and
Dante and Broncos I mean you can't just
slide the line to ad every time and if
you do that we got one-on-one matchups
that we can win so I think we had a
great game plan Wade
the more I'm around ways the more I'm
impressed and realize you don't stay in
this league for over 40 years if you're
not you don't have great game plans you
don't call great games because you can
you can have a great brilliant mind of
defense but if you don't call the game
at the right time call the right plays
against the right formations and plays
the Dauphin's is doing it doesn't really
matter and with Wade man he's he's
always on point he had a great game plan
for us to go out and execute and take
away somewhat their best players are not
inland and make the others beat us and
that's what we tried to do well you
mentioned to people right there I want
to I want to pause and hit on a little
bit more with you Eric Weddle you
mentioned ad you're referring to number
99 your program number one in the fans
heart that would be Erin Donald you're
back to that Defensive Player of the
Year you've gotten him from your
position you've got a front row seat
right behind what he can do what where
does he rank for you on that you played
he played in the backend of a defense
with some terrific players Eric on the
defensive line I wonder where he ranks
for you he's the most gifted talented
best player at any position I've ever
played with Wow it's um
he does things in practice and in games
that honestly don't no one in the league
can do and it's it amazes me but it also
puts in perspective of how hard he works
what a great teammate he is what a great
leader is a pro's Pro and it in a
translate how successfully is on in in
in the games just an amazing person and
I kid you not brought I wouldn't I'm not
caught up in all the hoopla I've been
around this game a long time and he's
literally one-of-a-kind on that front
that can do things I mean you get in a
situation like yesterday where they had
like a four or five yard run first down
and then second down he goes in there
mix of TfL for six-year of five-yard
loss and now we're back to third and ten
or realistically he could be third and
one or a first down and he makes just an
incredible play from his explosion from
his athleticism with his hands how
strong is is balance like
he's uh he's a joy to play with let me
tell you and then you mentioned
defensive coordinator Wade Phillips and
and his vast history he's also a
national treasure Eric I've been around
him away from from the field he's a he's
a national treasure you got a good wage
story for me Eric that that you can say
on the air here yeah yeah you know I
wear the Mike on the defense and you
know we go through the calls every day
and throughout practice and he pulls me
aside after one of the periods like he's
on a air everything good out there me
yeah yeah he's like you know it's funny
look what's that he's like you're gonna
be dreaming of my voice at night you
know that you're probably right because
I hear about 50 times a day so he's uh
he's comical he is he's uh a joy to be
around and Buddy he when he's serious
and when he has a point of view I mean
the respect that that he commands
without doing anything is pretty
impressive and then you know on the flip
side you've got somebody as youthful as
McVeigh and and when I heard that you
were signing with the Rams Eric I'm like
that is perfect not only is it Southern
California but I just would think you
and McVeigh would be us be you know hand
in glove and I know he's the offensive
guru and I it just seems he a perfect
fit with you and the head coach of the
Rams and I'm wondering if you've got a
good story on that front to hear yeah I
mean it's uh he's he's as real and
genuine as they come and he just gets it
as a head coach
he just gets you know how to get the
guys going how to work them how to back
off obviously his what he's done it
offensively and changes the game of what
he's done in over the last few years
Allen's corner and then head coaches
it's really impressive in and unheard of
the success he's had but it it comes
from who he is and the in the culture
and then in the you know the standards
that he said the standard is the
standard and and really taking a day by
day and getting the best out of it it's
just funny
that you know this offseason funny story
was Sean you know he really took a
ownership of the defense and really
diving in and honestly I kid you not
like it wasn't surprising if one day
down the line however many years that
he's both offensive coordinator and the
defensive coordinator of a team one day
because that's that's how smart he is
and how he really has learned and and
grown as a coach not only to help him as
often is coordinator but really will be
I practice and they'll be like hate your
technique was wrong on this player
you're supposed to be this leverage on
this call and this check and he's just
like another defensive coordinator out
there because he knows our defense
inside not because he literally took
every day to learn it but a side stories
because I'm rambling on is go for it you
know there are times an offseason a
training camp where I'd be like hey you
know we think about doing something like
this on defense we could we could really
manipulate this and any bikes let me
think about it in eternally like that's
a really good idea that's not a bad
imitation you would he would agree with
me on the side but at the weight you
know get around the bushes about it I
love it a couple more minutes left here
with Eric Weddle so how far can his team
go her long we threw this here what you
guys are talking about I mean this thing
this thing was all you know to the Super
Bowl last year so the experience and
what you learn I've never been in the
Super Bowl
obviously I've been to the AFC
Championship and there's still things
that I could learn from a lot of these
guys in this team and there's still
things that I can give to this team but
you know anything anything is possible
if you if you give it your all right if
you if you take it one week at a time
the old cliche but honestly the the way
this team the dynamic the mantras and
the mental focus are our leader and
there's no reason why we can't win at
all you know that's the goal that's been
the focus since losing that server bowl
and the dishes you made with this team
would last game the guys in here in the
draft picks and building this team the
way it's been you know we got to get
lucky with injuries you
ball has to bounce your way at some
point but I like our chances I like our
chances of going against anybody that's
for sure
alright and before I let you go you know
I follow you on twitter we follow each
other he sometimes communicate through
that as well Eric trettel
I saw after your after you get off the
field there seems to be something that
one would think a three-year-old would
eat not 13-year veteran in the National
Football League but a birthday cake ice
cream broken up rice krispies treats
birthday cake muffins fruity pebbles
sprinkles in marshmallow yeah you
tweeted this out yeah but it's not your
birthday auric what what what I don't
get this it does not compute your this
is you know everyone everyone has their
there vixens per se - is sugar and ice
cream or candy and you know I don't I'm
all ball during the season and and you
know it started years ago or I just
wanted to sacrifice something during the
week for the team to try to make myself
individually better in sacrifice to
demons so during the week I don't need
any sugar or sweets or ice cream okay
and then if hopefully we win and on
Sunday I smash as much ice cream candy
everything in sight to make up for the
week and to reward myself for all of the
hard work and sacrifice so that's really
how it started and created its own
phenomenon now and you know I enjoy it I
love I love the fans the kids love it I
love it and I mean butter ice cream that
means we're winning a bunch of games yay
for me exactly so you get what's your
Monday night looking like because this
gives itself scout here a little bit
because you're heading to Cleveland next
week I assume you're gonna be watching
the Browns Jets correct is evening oh
yeah yeah watch the watch there first
week's game last night and gonna start
watching just break them down a little
bit today and then obviously watch the
game tonight and dive into a more the
rest of the week so it'll be good to sit
back and relax and watch the game and
enjoy it from afar but also get ready
the matchup with those guys they got a
lot of great players over there so it'll
be a fun game all right Eric it seems
like you've got
on out of your car and going into the
rest of your day I really appreciate you
taking the time with me you're you're
really one of the best I hope this is a
regular occurrence you back here on this
show brother you got it buddy anytime
you know that you the man that's Eric
Weddle Ram safety at weddings beard for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app